hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and dance ever
so a while ago a long time ago I did a
video reaction review for fallout 4 and
I set up front don't know much about the
game and people were still like dude
you're such an idiot you don't know
anything about this game after I like
saw the trailer and I'm like I just
[ __ ] said I don't know much about the
game you [ __ ] [ __ ] I just want to
get that off my chest we're gonna
chicken before the water trailer feel
better and I feel this is the therapy
session instead I might treat my
subscribers like their therapist you
guys should be getting paid a lot more
yeah you guys should and a lot of you
guys can you stop being so mean yeah
therapy very bad they're not good
practice we're gonna check out fallout
for the wanderer trailer shrew Yan knows
more than I do let's see this
pressures on Dan looks like a Pixar
movie looks like a Pixar movie
that's because it's reality camp look at
his ass that's really good gameplay I
was like no that's this and that is a
whole person
place
I'm a wanderer
Garren haha for sponsored by generated
you know say what you want what weather
like actually you know shows off the
game at all like it doesn't it like it
doesn't show off any gameplay or
anything like that but like damn it
these sort of trailers just [ __ ]
awesome yeah there's an ironic tone let
me take it again I said ironic yes
there's an ironic tone in terms of they
had this like upbeat music but it's
dealing with a post-apocalyptic world
yet the idea of a wanderer than the
lyrics fits perfectly for what the vibe
is and I likes I like trailers that do
that they're doing music that you
wouldn't think would go with this but it
actually adds a cool twist to the tone
and style makes you want to play a part
of this like what I'm liking with some
trailers we've been seeing is they've
been a lot more fun instead of so
[ __ ] serious yeah and so seeing
another fun trailer and something a game
that's a little bit harder to just
promote in that way we're just a fun
yeah they managed to do it pretty well
good job marketing I mean one thing that
I've kind of come to terms with is
because lately we have been seeing more
like live-action trailers like this yeah
I remember like the first one that I
remember off the top of my head was a
halo 3 I think started promoting with
live-action trailers and the thing is
it's like why these don't show up the
game they don't show really show off the
story that much it's just kind of like
oh like check out this world and that's
exactly what we're getting here fallout
is about the world you know the world
after [ __ ] hits the fan and after
watching this trailer I'm like yeah I
want to [ __ ] go to there I don't want
to physically go there because that
looks like it would suck but like cool
world to be a part of in fantasy yeah
yeah that's what's great about this
trailers as we're watching this thing
and like seeing this world were like
[ __ ] yeah I'm ready I'm ready for this
game this is gonna be the game to own
when it comes out everyone knows that if
a post-apocalyptic situation happened be
the badass longer with the dog you know
you got the Mad Max you got the I am
Legend
you know and then book of Elah like dad
asked Wanderers in post-apocalyptic
world that's what I'm gonna be when [ __ ]
hits the fan mm-hmm
with no Doug yeah when all the fat
people start eating human beings cuz we
run out of food
yeah I'm gonna be part of the fat people
side I'm also make them a wanderer
wanderer gonna be both Mac my fat wonder
I'm gonna go I'm not gonna be like the
badass wandering would be that like
slightly above-average on her like not
enough to like stand out where's like oh
[ __ ] it's Dan kill that [ __ ]
more like oh hey who's that I don't care
he's probably taste good kind of a loner
but what as and then like you that you
eat me anyway I eat you
regardless apocalypse or not you're
going down gotta take out the serial
killer before he does it me pick so they
look like a serial joke I would just
like to officially announce my departure
from the real rejects is with a heavy
heart you be the second person this year
shits covered it over it's too real for
me know you're dealing with this
territory you could say I had a fallout
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel and bringing up some dark
memories if you want to you can
subscribe to the real rejects if you
want to if you want more dark memories
and dark moments in your face that's
your yeah become a reject Ori after a
guy named Gregor II is one secksy
slightly chubby more on the fat side
[ __ ] who really needs to work
more on his health habits I'm concerned
for him and you can check out dansgaming
channel with not so dark moments become
a cyber Nick Cannon today acceptable of
sex
Jerry Walsh a all the way from UK love
your YouTube channel Yugos always put a
smile on my face it's my small e on my
face
well the UK Terry will share get lad
come on fire a lot of do things to ya a
lot to pick your teeth Oh stupid day
let's see what you look like
you do not look like a serial killer but
you do look like you work in a comic
book store often jerk off alone
obviously who really drips off and
groups these days there's a certain
group of people who have certain
crystals that they have to Jack out with
their brows in order to energize our
crystal I know real thing you have never
been willing to jack off of me cuz I
don't need to church we don't need to
tell our girlfriends I don't want to
touch you I just want a buddy least
that's what that guy in Craigslist once
said to me a long time ago how that go I
never did it then that seems like it's
your own problems wasn't comfortable
enough of them kind of not doing it come
on
no plate long now play along now play
along with the bid I'm playing along in
the bed this is me say no anyway Terry
go jerk off